[Applause]
the amazon rainforest is on fire again
whole mountains hills and valleys
engulfed in smoke
some of these fires are absolutely huge
stretching as far as the eye can see
in every direction beneath the canopy of
these ancient trees
the fires rage the heat from the blade
is absolutely astonishing
we filmed as trees exploded into flame
burning like a torch these trees
are gone forever the brazilian
government
says the amazon is not on fire but these
are our pictures
we witnessed ten fires in just one part
of para state in the amazon
it's already the most deforested part of
the rainforest
deforestation that's changed the
ecosystem
there are wildfires around the globe
particularly in the united states
but this is a rain forest it shouldn't
be happening
but listen to the fire
controlling the fires is almost
impossible firefighters struggle to stop
the flames spreading from cattle
pastures
to the rainforest above this
firefighting team
is responsible for 84 000 square
kilometers of land
that's just a bit larger than scotland
and there are five of them yes five
with nothing more than fire beaters and
water packs
all things considered they're remarkably
effective but they aren't actually
putting it out
the fires restart constantly
as the blaze spreads they try to steer
cattle to safety
but they are terrified and stamped away
the real danger here is the speed of the
fire
it moves as fast as the wind right the
fire
you almost put it out when it's coming
out it's really fast now
it's not out of control but if they've
withdrawn it's so so hot
nhs burning out the trade you can see
you can't see behind but this huge
forest out there as well
but uh the wind is off it's really
dangerous
really really dangerous
we joined this fire fight for two days
but it already been burning for four
the ranch owner cladys dos santos hasn't
given up the fight
but in 20 years he's never seen it this
bad
he blames the climate
[Music]
actually stopping the fires when the
trees are alight is impossible for the
team
it's too ill-equipped they only go in
when the temperature and winds drop
but that can change in an instant and
that is deadly
now zildo valente de silva's in charge
he's making decisions on the hoof in
reality
it's guess work you can't see more than
a few feet in here
they try to build fire breaks clearing
the forest floor
and cutting up smoldering tree trunks
it's not
much but it's the best they can do
criticism of the brazilian government's
indifference to the amazon rainforest
was deafening last year but the fires
are back
there are thousands of them covet 19 may
have changed
the way we live but what happens here
what happens to our climate right now
could one day determine whether our
planet actually lives
still ramsey sky news in the amazon
rainforest